tu es un homme maintenant va voir le
monde et montre lui qui tu es j'ai le
bonheur d'avoir un jeune garçon mon
service m kelly voilà son nom thürler il
est temps que tu te fasses à mon jet
apprendre des choses actu et en hommes
rien n'est jamais gratuit dans ce monde
mon fils soit un homme accompli tour
destin du n'est pas l'homme que tu
prétends être tué un petit garçon qui
cherchent un capitaine qui lui disent
quoi faire tuer on est des rebelles des
guerrières vous portez tous des roms
y'a rien qui fait plus peur aux hommes
que la folie
[Musique]
vous voulez qu'on bâtisse d'une arme à
feu
oui messieurs vous êtes allé prendre dès
maintenant
tu mourrais pour tenir sa part
[Musique]
tu y as ta mère que je lui fais mes
amitiés
foot un homme peut pas changer le passé
ni changer le cours de son destin
tu es un homme maintenant tu es mon
petit a fait de moi le meurtrier le plus
froid qui ait jamais existé mais
d'autres connaissant la vérité dirais
que je suis un héros
sa puissance liens du sang la chair et
le sang